10 miles south of the great pyramids of
giza
lies the necropolis of saqqara
today egyptologist chris norton travels
here to investigate what triggered
over a thousand years of pyramid
building
he's been granted rare access to explore
restricted areas of this necropolis
this is a pretty exciting moment for me
because
i've never been inside before
this ancient cemetery is home to 11
pyramids
and hundreds of tombs
but one structure dominates all others
the first pyramid
ever built this is where it all began
it is the first monumental building in
stone
anywhere in the world constructed more
than 4
500 years ago this is the step
pyramid tomb of pharaoh jose a king of
egypt's third dynasty
it's a revolutionary masterpiece
designed by egypt's pioneer architect
imhotep his achievement was massive
not just for the egyptians but for
humankind
born as a commoner imhotep rose to
become
pharaoh joseph's trusted advisor and
eventually
his chief architect
he invented the stepped pyramid
using stone blocks instead of mud bricks
allowing him to build ever bigger
more than 2 000 years after imhotep's
death
he was worshipped as a god all the way
up to greek and roman times
chris wants to discover for himself what
inspired imhotep to design
his groundbreaking step pyramid he
climbs to higher ground
to examine the shape of older burial
structures that surround it
they're called mastabas and they are
these sort of squat square
platforms slightly sloping
inwardly inclining walls chris
can make out traces of these simple
structures within
imhotep's design now that we're getting
closer to the pyramid you can really see
this series of platforms one on top of
another
so the bottom one in some sense is a
master birth it's just the addition of
these successive layers that make it
into a pyramid
and it's an incredible achievement
architecturally
[Music]
built from over 500 000 tons of
limestone
constructed in mastaba style layers
the step pyramid stands over 200 feet
high
then the tallest building in the world
its impact on the ancient egyptian
landscape was huge
ten more kings replicated imhotep's
design
determined to attain the same status as
the pharaoh of the first pyramid
their tombs became some of the most
iconic sacred buildings on the planet
each growing the necropolis until it
stretched five miles across the desert
to create a sprawling city of the dead
today imhotep's masterpiece still
dominates the egyptian desert
but while his structures survive no
trace of the man himself
has ever been found
[Music]
you